hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay I
turned up the gamma just a bit not all
the way cuz I don't want to ruin the
atmosphere but I noticed that it's
darker when I put it up on YouTube that
it is when I'm playing the game I mean
it's still like freaking dark like is a
little light in here but if you look
down that hallway still pitch black so I
just wanted to make sure that you guys
could see what I was seeing all right
but anyway alright what we're left off I
had hahaha
I pushed that button not going in there
and that opened that it didn't get of a
cutscene to what that opens so
I don't really know oh ha ha brick
favorite they don't seem to follow
upstairs very well uh anyway um I don't
really know what that did but
like
cuz I I don't know it didn't give a
cutscene so I really don't know where to
go and I'm kind of turned around a bit
because I don't know exactly what's what
okay so his green door maybe it was
green button so maybe now I'm looking
for a green door okay
where the heck I see a green door
hmm hello friend going this way we try
going back down this down in here cuz I
didn't really explore this area cuz my
light kept going out this is may just
lead okay Pat is still there ah where do
you come from
ah Oh what the hell is going on this is
different this is different this is
different what where am i oh
go away go away I see your hand oh go
ahead oh where the heck am i what
okay those are the padded cells oh go
away man uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
please where am I going oh my god what
do we do whatever you oh wait where
where okay there's the red room these
are all huh okay he's gone
huh this red room okay there wasn't
anything else by the red room but I did
manage to pick up some batteries mmm
come at me bro ah come on I can take you
yeah yeah that's right
Oh someone said that I need to get off
the table stop being such a pansy
well maybe they didn't say ah ah okay
all right I'm gonna be a pansy I'm all
run by him ah GRU ha what the hell
what can I move oh this is to the Blue
Room but the Blue Room is blocked off
that's the blue door
ah freaky frak I'm out of help ah what
am i doing where am I going
how did I get turned around I'm wasting
battery Oh God
try again going deftly moving past you
ah come on deftly moving past you
Briscoe this is the Blue Room again
what's this oh I found it
I have one health hahahaha have one
health one uh thing in the trash can
oh that helps
I guess ah ha ha I have no bullets ah ah
ah
I can't get through there yeah I can
make it head
skilled job yeah bet okay bro dodge ah
ah did the glass break I think the last
Brook maybe I can dodge God God Oh Oh
get through ah almost through this would
let me jump up miss Baek ah balls damn
it okay um I need to go back to the
quicksave where I had more health than
that cuz that's problem oh oh oh oh oh I
don't think ah
oh no autosave Oh balls
Oh balls this is not enough not enough I
need gun gun bullets uh let me try one
more time to get passing see hope dodge
God and then dodge I get it I can get it
I can get it I'm good yeah yeah damn it
what is with you what is wrong with you
and that is so weird
did did she oh don't even oh okay
I got a Oh at least I know where to go
now okay if I load up the saber I stir
Oh God um
ah you were there but you were blocking
the way out this is right here yeah Oh
like that okay now that I have 30
I get 31 health and maybe that'll be
enough to get by
hmm no go oh okay screw that up try to
get huh
yes me oh maybe I should try to kill it
maybe if I jump on top of it like huh
and then I can't jump on top of it I
can't jump on top of it oh oh
legs are blocking it huh
damn it stop hitting me ha oh I got
blown up I don't know I'll try to get
through the door you oh oh damn it
we have it I just got to get him to miss
me the on the first one and then I'm
good
ah [ __ ] ah that's me what mod op stage
ah ha oh maybe I tried go through the
bottom one missed missed there we go oh
[ __ ] nope no such luck [ __ ] what I gotta
do
Oh missed missed nope [ __ ] oh how the
[ __ ] I got when I just had one health I
somehow managed to get past enough to
break the window but then he like just
murders me come on why do I keep getting
hit on that first one what happened at
me Pro dodging nope I can't break it but
just not getting through ah yes give me
through goddammit maybe I can't get
through there our clan hospital oh yeah
nope no such luck dammit dammit alright
um I hate to resort resort to this but
I'm thinking I might have to drop
oh [ __ ] can you not do that use high
quality model oh no David leather Hoff
nice hmm I guess I can't oh oh balls all
balls Oh balls
Oh balls
oh boy oh just yeah just one melee like
from him yep just one melee that's all
it takes
it's not like he moves or anything he's
just he just stands there like a lump
this does nothing how do you expect me
to kill him
I have no bullets ha ha
I have no bullets leave me alone you
[ __ ] ah ah all right
I just gotta keep trying to get through
the window I guess okay you can't get
through the bottom one and close I just
need to not get hit by the first one
dodge and nope one melee [ __ ] off huh oh
this is aggravating this is just the
worst oh they make it so it's almost
impossible to get through on low health
ah ah damn it
like a [ __ ] tracks me like a frickin
laser targeting system god damn it all
right [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ]
this [ __ ] dammit
Omo Tommy Tommy oh come on come on come
come oh my god please kill him can you
not die oh I got ya yes yes yes yes yeah
yeah say that [ __ ] yeah yes
yes ah I can't deal with that out there
huh get me out get me out let me out
Oh fu buddy if you and your stupid hat
take that God this knife does nothing it
does nothing
Oh
Oh No Oh
okay now your your turn come on how can
I hit you let's stand on top of your
head there we go oh one more come on
bring it
let's go kissee there you are come here
come closer
so what talk with you there you are and
this is totally not cheating because
there's four of them how else do you
expect me to kill them all all right
another one down there's just huh damn
it damn it
stupid quick say button being right next
to the not quick say button and there we
go three down and here's the last one
you want to play would you go buddy are
you still down there what you doing what
you doing buddy what's going on Twiggy
what you doing what you doing ha ha up
hill I will jump on your head ah that's
not on your head
jump on your head
there we go ah come on I said jump on
head there we go
it's my new tactic to kill every monster
in the game ever jump on their head
hahah so pro okay I get out here and
then I do a gun click but I'm gonna
really save this frickin ammo like not
use it unless I absolutely need it quick
what the hell am I supposed to go now
mmm what dear hell I supposed to go
through candy brick all these can break
well that would have saved me some time
oh I'm not gonna survive that fall oh I
did I did it
okay okay what happened ah pills huh
thank you thank you pills
thank you thank you so much booze ah got
water down there oh there's a ladder
right there okay OOP got that are pro
that Oh for a little bit I got I got
enough whoa what the hell that look
Klima bulette er well no it's really not
how I got pwned okay god come on what
what are you doing what are you doing to
me
me I didn't I didn't even do anything it
just pushed me seriously quick into
legit like that okay whatever
no no no no I don't I can't do this I
can't deal with ism just stay right
there stay right there actually
I'm gonna go back cuz I can't I can't
afford to lose all this health they do
not give me enough health to deal with
this and I will not ah I will not be
made a fool of actually a Ladykiller
come on there we go
stay stay stay stay stay dang damn it
alright fine you're getting the gun
there's no way around it I just got a
gun yeah ah what coming hive [ __ ] oh why
is this Ari ah come on
oh you know what fine good I gotta end
this episode here
fine come on
thank you guys so much for watching ooh
let's get hard on hard anyway thanks
again everyone for watching hope y'all
enjoyed it and as always I'll see you in
the next part
bye bye